talking tough on Gaza plays especially
well in Israel at election time this
senior politician wants to be the next
defense minister he told Sky News all
weapons in the Palestinian enclaves must
be destroyed
bombing aerial bombing and every single
rocket factory every single missile
storage site hunting down every single
terrorist on an ongoing basis
I would affect the full force of Israel
on Hamas the terror organization and
their decimated how to deal with the
militant group Hamas that rules Gaza is
a key talking point in the run-up to the
election
on the 9th of April a topic that's been
amplified this week by Palestinian
rocket attacks and Israeli airstrikes
Israel's Prime Minister visited troops
on the Gaza border before traveling
north to open a new stretch of road
including this tunnel using the
opportunity to say he's ready to wage a
broad military campaign in Gaza but only
as a last resort
Israel's longest-serving Prime Minister
despite facing the prospect of criminal
charges including bribery for
Palestinians the elections mean a
continuation of what they see as an
increasingly hard right agenda with
Israeli politicians seeking ever greater
powers at their expense the case of
today six and half million Israelis with
six and half million Palestinians
sharing the same land in an apartheid
system functioning as a reality on the
ground can the world opened their eyes
to see this reality he says Donald
Trump's support for Israel has made
things worse we are left alone
there is no partner and there is no
international and wind committed to the
international law to change the status
quo or to freeze or to contain or to
stop Israeli aggressions there's a
fragile calm in Israel after the Gaza
clashes as Egyptian mediators try to
negotiate a ceasefire but this will be
tested on Saturday when Palestinians
mark the first anniversary of protests
at the Gaza border fence Israeli forces
are under stand by the potential for
conflict is real Deborah Haim Sky News
Jerusalem